here's where we had gone we took this
guy right I was born man I don't no idea
what that looks like you can't simply
play the geometrical game and think oh
yeah exactly what the difference of
those squares is right well we just had
to do some algebra with it
we knew what excuse me what each of
these was missing something off this no
that's okay yeah it was all right we did
deserves two squares we saw some real
parts dissapears imaginary plans
disappear and eventually once we
simplified down this is where we ended
okay now to your member there was a
couple of extra steps that these are
crucial ones I don't once I want to
re-emphasize this morning before move
from here to here how do I get from that
to this there's anyone in the bottom
yeah okay so I had to think about like
what is this thing in terms of its
boundaries that's that's where I was
trying to go right so when you think
about it without boundaries the place
you have to go is by definition by
definition the modulus of this complex
number is going to be the square root of
the square root of what the real part
squared plus the imaginary part squared
right it's its undoing PI powers so
that's why we had that zero square which
was the real part that you were talking
about plus bxy which is the imaginary
part right you don't need to write the
either now that is going to be and from
there we just get our equation to had
some absolute values in it that gave us
these boundaries the familiar one an X
and minus 1 of X ok so far so good
so now let's finish this thing off what
are we really careful about which part
of the region that we're after and you
can do some intuition we saw ok we want
a distance from the origin and we want
it to be a big distance that's why we
guessed we let the outside let's confirm
it ok so when I test this where am I
going to put this this is a point where
am I going to place it into my working
now I've got I've got a real putt there
x equals 1 and I've got an imaginary
part there y equals a half but where do
I put those x equals 1 and y equals 1/2
so I've got some traces I'm going here
or here like these represent the same
equation don't they I've just evaluated
a little bit okay I'm gonna go for this
one
good morning I'm gonna go for this one
because you know we're helping you sort
of flex by complex number muscles really
interested try and get myself practicing
thinking of those tips so let's have a
good left hand side there right the left
hand side is going to be equal to the
modulus 2i times X times y right so
that's one how you came back so that's
the modulus of half I now what does that
mean
tell me geometrically what that means
what's it referring to what is the
modulus it's the distance from the
origin right it's the distance from zero
to that point where is that point
well that point hasn't happens is right
here it's right there okay keep in mind
this is not the distance to there it's
the distance student there these are two
different points okay once you import
then you get a different thing I bet
this is just 1/2 does that satisfy my
inequality or not it doesn't does it
I want it to be greater than one it's
quite clearly not greater than one so I
say greater than one I mean I could say
less than or equal to but all I want to
know is does it satisfy my inequality or
not okay so therefore I would say not in
the region now ordinarily it would be
probably sufficient from here to say
well okay if I found the spot it's not
in the region it just must be the other
side okay but being that we're in
complex on malaria we might as well just
confirm by testing another point and we
already suggested this one right so I'm
going to test is N equals one plus 2i
all right I'm gonna pop it back in here
and remember I'm actually trying to see
whether this inequality is true or not
so I don't just put it into here and say
oh it's greater than one I don't know
whether it's greater than one or not
until I've done my work okay
so that's why I say left-hand side
so left-hand side of that inequality we
have super dry times what what I put in
here one times two
there's my real and imaginary part right
and then feast more josephus so this is
the modulus that UI which again is the
distance from the origin of two to I
which is a p.m. which is two units right
does that satisfy my equality what it
does right is greater than one therefore
it's in the region okay so from there
that's enough
excuse me that's enough numerical proof
I think to be able to say this is in
this is our I'm gonna shade up here like
you have to do some kind of
demonstration of like what why am I
getting this value versus that value if
what you've got like down here is not
something really obvious like it's to
the right of this line or it's above
this line or it's inside my circle or
outside my circle and this is not really
a common case so that's why I'm gonna go
ahead and test okay that's what I'll
have got in the in the first project
right and you can pretty quickly see
what's going to happen all the way over
here and over here so I've got four
distinct regions where points will
satisfy this is equality here okay